هو البعث الرئيسي تصفيات هذه الاوضاع
تصحيح هذه الاوضاع بخلق الاستقرار والامن
ونشر العدل والمساواه هذه عوامل ساهمت في
نشوء وتطور الدرعيه واصبحت
تميز المشروع السعودي يعني في امارات كانت
موجوده في العينه في غيرها في حتى في
مناطق شمال نجد وكذا ولكن لم تبتسم بهذه
السمه الرؤيه الوحدويه هذه او الرؤيه
الشامله الامام محمد بن سعود استخدم سياسه
المسامحه وحسن الجوار وبدا بمساعده حكام
الاقاليم او المناطق المجاوره لتحقيق
الاستقرار في بلادهم
معناته عنده مشروع الرجل وعندما ادرك
هؤلاء الامراء جدوى سياسه الامام بن سعود
انضموا الى دولته طواعيه نعم وانت هذه
المرحله الاولى محمد بن سعود هي مرحله
التاسيس بالمناسبه هي يوم التاسيس نسبه
اليه قلت ايضا في موضع اخر من هذا الكتاب
واعجبتني هذه اللقطه تقول بعد ما استعرضت
جهود محمد بن سعود الاولى كثيرا ما تظلم
للامانه ثم قلت فنشات وحده في العارض ثم
وحده في نجد يعني العارض احد اقاليم نجد
كان الاساس توحيد العارض ثم من خلفه
استكمال مشروع التوحيد في نجمه في الجزيره
العربيه حتى حتى وصلت حدود الدوله
السعوديه الاولى من التوسع والانتشار الى
نواحي السيناء والى حلب في سيناء والى حلب
في بلاد الشام في سوريا الان والى كربلاء
في العراق الدوله السعوديه الاولى من
الرغم من حيث المساحه الجغرافيه هي اكبر
كيان سياسي سعودي عبر التاريخ